[Music]
in doing it wrong news
submitted by not my goodies a mom tries
to teach her son a lesson and winds up
arrested
oh what does she do nice yeah
so this mom here she
was trying to take her 12 year old son
to the dentist
and then when her son was like
no i don't want to go i don't want to go
he climbed on top punched
he climbed on top of the car and then
she was like
all right mama bro we're going to the
dentist so she drove two miles with her
kid
on the roof of the car oh [ __ ] damn
that's some teen wolf [ __ ]
that's kind of cool that is teen wolf
[ __ ] what is that
michael j fox movie very famous very
famous film it's like a cult classic
it's car surfing
well anyway yeah so she uh she was
arrested and charged with child
endangerment and reckless endangerment
yeah i mean she was pretty dumb but she
didn't drive because i read this one too
she didn't drive him to the dentist she
drove him to the police station with him
on the car
oh that's right is she really [ __ ] up
yeah she's right so like she was like oh
we're we're going but then she was like
oh now that
changes the story completely i know i
forgot that she thought the police were
going to
like teach him a lesson the best that is
funny and then they were like uh
actually turn around
put you you know hey we're going to
handcuff you
and i'm like i'm so right when we look
this [ __ ] up you are [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you have no idea how right i am right
now i'm like if i had
a million dollars i'd put it all in
right now and then we look it up and i'm
like
oh my god how did i [ __ ] up this much
and why did i have to talk this much
[ __ ]
yeah like to be on that level where
you're like we're driving to the police
station because i'm so right
and then you get arrested what did she
think the cops were going to do
teach them a lesson she's like like like
i think like scold the kids
she needed some sort of like male
authority figure or something to help
her with herself i also feel like if
you're 13 that's not
child endangerment you just have a
[ __ ] for a kid well 12 but yeah
or yeah same [ __ ] 12 13 i feel like
that's [ __ ] years
yeah by 12 you should already have
enough skills
and being able to balance on a call hold
on so true
if you don't yeah you kind of deserve
yeah falling off of it
i actually want to report the police for
not having for not handcuffing this 12
year old
for being for having whack balance well
actually he has good balance because he
stayed on top of the car exactly he made
it all the way the police station
so obviously he wasn't in danger he
should get this key to the city
i don't know about that the speed limit
on that road is 40 miles an hour i don't
know how fast she
and he stayed on so he wasn't in danger
at all circus needs to hire this guy
yeah so this is sheree circus with
dental benefits yeah i want to see how
he car surfed
i don't have that i have a photo of the
mom her name's sheree she's 36 years old
what if it's just like a minivan with a
rack on the ceiling and all she did was
hold on was it at night
at night no because he was supposed to
go to the dentist how could there be no
photographs of this incident i know
right like if i see a kid
i'm like the first thing i do like what
i'm saying yeah
yeah sorry i hope there wasn't any
sudden stops
oh that'd be awesome that's why this
kid's a badass he just
rolls off and then she runs him over
because two miles you probably hit a
stop sign or two or red light or
something
i wonder what you're supposed to do like
as you're coming up to a stop sign do
you like
prep and then get down or do you jump i
hope there were low tunnels or
or she went through places with a lot of
lee like a branches
she intentionally i would do that on
purpose what would have been sick is if
she drove
like like very slowly to the car wash oh
yeah she's like
good luck little buddy you want to clean
your teeth we're going to clean your
whole [ __ ] body
that's right and they're like you can't
do this [ __ ] that'd be amazing but the
automatic car wash you can get
away with it oh that's the one with all
the guys there yeah
they usually always have guys there
though in the beginning but not the
automatic one no like the drive through
just pay yeah at the drive-thru ones
they have guys there no that's
i've never seen i'm gonna take her to an
automatic car wash after this
yeah there's one right next to the
office that's five bucks and you put
quarters in and there's nobody there
dude
at lunch we're gonna i'm gonna take you
to ten we're gonna go we're all gonna
get car washes
there's no one there jk news live at the
car lot doing it bud
and they're like why'd you pick this i
feel like could you have picked anything
else i don't know
anything not take me to ten car washes i
feel like you right now in your fight
with nikki like i'm gonna put
10 million dollars on this that there's
a guy at every single one and then we
pull up to the first one and there's
nobody there pretty much yeah
how it works out every time but i have
such confidence though when i when it
happens
i already hear it dude yeah i hear it
why do i do it to myself
they'd be like we'd rather go to trader
joe's to see those pickles
than this [ __ ] car hella true six
minutes of picking wait what's the
pickles
oh we did a lot of pickle talk one time
and we should be able to do like four
minutes of just
pickle talk and then what another one
was a fig talk i haven't seen that one
yet
you haven't seen that one yet hasn't
come through the line yet dude you poor
thing man
the amount of content that you have to
listen to of all of us man
yeah she likes it though she's always
laughing i don't mind it but i do hear
the same stories over and over and over
and i'm sitting there like who's the
biggest culprit of that
joe david you're starting to do it now
i'm doing it you've been on here long
enough yeah well let me tell you
something all you [ __ ] saying that [ __ ]
you try sitting here four thousand hours
not repeating a story or two ideas my
god
especially if the story triggers that
memory yeah
and it usually does we've only lived so
long and we have so many
experiences make up some [ __ ] how about
that i'm here
what david does doesn't he there you go
only fight stories that's the ongoing
joke that david makes up which he
doesn't
i know because david's like these kids
think i'm like 20 years old
like his roommate that pissed [ __ ]
orange soda out of his dick or some [ __ ]
that doesn't drink water he made that
one up but i'll see makeup
he's going to spend the rest of the
episode like roasting david and all the
stores not even here
oh man anyway yeah this mom driving to
the police station with her
son i totally forgot that little part
that's a huge part
too so there's a lot of stories i had to
read okay
exactly try doing that [ __ ] for 10 000
hours bro
forget it i mean all she needed to do
was get a
hose and spray the kid down from the car
i know get off from there this reminds
me when i convinced nikki i was
colorblind
oh my god why did you do that anyway
like what was the point
for the [ __ ] is there ever a point to
why steve does things
yeah that's true oh by me but that was
so specific like why not like you're
allergic to something like why why did
you part of the context or the
circumstances that's what i'm trying to
figure out what was the circumstance
i don't know okay nikki says
it's because uh uh she thinks that you
felt weird about her treating you stupid
or something yeah
that's why i stopped it yeah oh well you
stopped it but why'd you start
oh that's why i don't know oh okay she
okay
i just wanted to repeat another story so
everyone should be talking to you
really slow because yeah
are you running another bit now that's
well i'm trying to think of another
story i've told
more than once but i don't know i'm
saying right now in your relationship
with nikki she doesn't know
oh i'm not i don't have any bits running
right now i don't think oh
you forgot you guys you guys have play
around a lot together we do
but you guys don't like like practical
jokes middle finger fights are so fun
those are awesome that's
that's a fun one we've been doing that
for a long time and i finally have been
recording i always click on your story
just to see if it's going to be another
middle finger fight
and then you're disappointed lately i'm
sorry it's like an ad for dollar shave
club and i'm like oh
i will say that for the dollar shave
club i had a great time because
i did the shocker in the photo and they
didn't even notice and they didn't know
that's tired but they they're they're
they're a little edgy though
and i didn't know it was beautiful i
love those people i'm gonna report you
no please don't nobody tell email dollar
shave club right now
so you'll never get a sponsor i'm gonna
tell the irs too yeah
what is the irs yeah right like what the
[ __ ]
are you paying taxes on that dollar
shave club add money did you pay taxes
on the shocker sir
yeah it's licensed
dude how would you get them down
no i just be like let your [ __ ] teeth
rot like i'm not going to go in any pain
like if that's what you want use a hose
it works for everything dogs kids
plants ooh a pet a pen of a pot of hot
water just [ __ ] throw it on this is
gonna burn his ass and then my car melts
cold water would be better it'd be less
it's not satisfying
i think there's whatever they love you
take it away that until and then you
keep taking
all the things they love but i really
love you you're my favorite thank you
that's funny no it's like i will become
you abandon him no i'm i'll be
emotionally unavailable to you for one
month
oh [ __ ] the worst that is conditional
love yeah i could do it depends on the
age right because
if they're like the younger they are
they'll be like i need a hug no
damn it's more but if they're 12 or 13
you're like you're not getting any more
wheat
then it's like oh no more we i'm taking
away all your weed growing
yup well there was this like period of
time when isaac was a real handful
and so we had to i sat him down what age
is this so i could prepare myself oh man
it was like
six seven a little bit of eight i
remember japan
yeah that's what my dad said i said my
dad said uh from ages four it's funny
because he's talking to me
about me but he's referring to like it's
some other kid he's like okay
like kids become [ __ ] at age four
all day until when they're like 18. and
i'm like are you talking about me
and this is why you had a great
relationship with your father this is
why you had a great relationship so
there's 12 years of
[ __ ] hetery yeah so then around that
time we sat him down and i was like all
right listen we have to create
a list of like punishment sort of
so then i was like okay the first thing
here if you
misbehave then it's going to be no this
no there's no and then the most extreme
one
was like drowning no it was similar to
what you guys were saying it was like a
month of no hugs because he loves hugs
so bad damn you told isaac you were
going to give him any hugs but they
never got there
because that was like the most extreme
yeah i did it though
that's great he he never misbehaved that
bad so wait you made a list with him
so like you're with him and you're like
with him if you do this i'm taking this
away that's tight
are you like hey name something that
that you love i did
and then he's like liver and onions and
you're like you're like guess what
if you do this you're not having liver
and onions and he's like oh
it's dark that [ __ ] would have never
worked on me
when i was a kid my parents would always
be like oh we're going to take this
we're going to take this and i would sit
there and be like fine take it all i
don't care send me to prison i don't
care
i didn't care i was like take all of it
i don't care i'll sit here in silence i
think that's why asian princess beat the
[ __ ] out of kids yeah cuz i would
pretend
i would be like no not my radio no
not my tv and i'm like i'll give a [ __ ]
i'm gonna watch it at my friend's house
yeah but no one likes to get hit yeah
you can't really pretend that you can't
pretend
that's true that's true no but isaac he
was he was so
like oh because he would have no
reaction sometimes
like he'll mess like he'll act up and
then we'll be yelling at him and he'll
just be there like stone-faced i'll
remember that's why they hit kids
what you do i remember that you throw a
blanket over and we have a blanket party
yup you know what make a party hell yeah
everyone beats his ass no you throw a
blanket over somebody and then you beat
him with a phone book
and so it leaves but it leaves no marks
or a bar of soap
but if they're a kid if they're a kid
you use a highlights magazine because
it's much thinner
highlights and it's something that they
love
i hated highlights oh wow really i loved
highlights
it was the stupidest magazine it was
only at the dentist and you were like
what the [ __ ]
had a subscription sticky too like the
pages were always stuck together
yeah you use their favorite book
whatever it is you fill the blanket over
and use your favorite book
damn yeah that's love
[Music]
bye